im 91
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge von der
zusammenschau hallo halte spielen gemina
kraft und kraft zusammen stecken
okay du hast es nicht anders gewollt ich
drei wenn du den diamanten daraus nimmst
ich habe nichts genommen ich hab nur in
die kiste einmal angeschaut die tochter
soll obduziert extra voll aufnahmen
gestellt hast
wie sollte ich denn china irgendwas raus
ist der diamant avec ist doch jammern
dass weg nein doch nicht
ok jetzt wird dann aus angefragt doch
nicht lügt auch nicht wir können einen
frieden regel kosten von mixed wir aber
nicht was an zündet sich mit angepackt
auch nur zu erinnerung ich hab 31 level
ich habe 31 level
ich habe 31 level also macht nicht
gehört irgendwie feuer gesetzt aber
wurzeln finde ist dass jetzt auf dem
dach bewusstes jung ich habe 31 27 weil
al wazzan die level mit in die hand zu
tun
ja weil ich als wenn ich jetzt in höhe
junge selber diamanten suche ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit hoch dass ich sterbe
aber gibt die extra gesagt wir schließen
letzten folge dass ich dir welche wieder
bringen
es gibt auch zwei neue wieder so kam mir
zwei neue wieder gibst alles okay das
habe ich auch letzte folge ja gesagt
nein hast du nicht doch nein doch nicht
ohne grund wenn alle leute gezählt habe
in meinem review
mal witzig mal sehen ich werd ich mal
was gutes
ich war 20 was er dann für theorien
aufgestellt wurde
rot ist sofort und feuers sind erschwert
es voll witzig so witzig was dann immer
so viele theorien aufgestellt werden
du kannst den hat oder warum kommt keine
treffer mehr
habt ihr wird bestritten auf sein
engagement kommt oder weiß sind ja auch
bei dass das ist das ist dass alle leute
dass alle leute das immer verraten dass
ich wenn man hier eine geheime kiste hat
nicht an verraten dass alle einfach
viele nachrichten bekommen hätten das
ist richtig scheiße von euch einfach
ohne witz das ist blöd weil wir müssen
jetzt aber diamanten und obsidian suchen
400 kisten oder braun hat nie ändern
was braucht man für den ändert ist noch
mal ein auge doch oder kann ja mal ein
auge
ich weiß nicht ich habe ein brand von
minecraft massenhausen ich mache gerade
weit unter öffentliche grundstücke das
kann ich nicht tolerieren das werde ich
auch nicht tolerieren ist es nicht in
ordnung dass facebook gefragt was für
fragen ist so gibt hast du eine frage
gefunden
ich sagte du machst das also ich hätte
ja die frage stellen bekomme ordentlich
einmal die ganze zeit voll falsches ein
also größer aus bielefeld von einer
bestimmten person und die musik gefällt
ihr selber was küsse ich weiß nicht
gesagt dass er vergessen dann dachte ich
helfe ihm gefällt das
aber das gefällt mir ich bin voll teure
gefällt mir ein typ ist voll cool der
das geschrieben hat er das vielleicht
erstmal keine ahnung also tollen team
kam nur nicht an der k man so was was
halten sie davon dass die playstation 4
jetzt so ganz urplötzlich einfach raus
kommt sie kaufen werden und so was alles
was haltet ihr davon dass die grüne
verzögerung bekommen hat aber voll
komisch dass er bei offerte platz fünf
hat bis 15 gibt man das essen beinahe
verdoppeln
besser ist gegen spinnen das technische
spitzel schlage kanal ist es sofort rot
und brennt und lud in drei das heißt es
die wahrscheinlichkeit steigt dass ich
seit excel coole sachen herausbekomme
yahoo
die schnauze darum gehe ich jetzt zurück
in mein haus und die hätte man darf ja
und erinnere mich daran dass ich das die
koordinaten von der vom spor mir gesagt
wurden hat es mal jetzt man aber nur
einmal vorbeischauen
weil sonst vergisst das war okay bevor
ich jetzt in eine höhle gehen die ich
auf jeden fall erstmal schafe scheren
wenn du bist doch chancen
naja thema thema li na ja vielleicht
erst mal runter machen würde
station war das thema gar nicht
eventuell allerdings drin
nein hab ich nicht ausgeben wird soll
komplett gelöscht ist nirgendwo mehr
drauf und total geht die pro tag
manchmal
die ganzen folgeschäden quartal schäden
von empire
jaja so riesen losgeschickt und jetzt
stürzt immer ab alles
nein ich meine das mit dem jäger so das
ist ja komplett im arsch was aber auch
dass eltern runde pennen gehn jetzt bei
mir war eine ganz ganz schlechte
verbindungen seines sogar hochlädt nein
doch nicht so aber das ganz ganz ganz
ganz schlecht
ich hatte schon gefunden
auch nochmal ähneln also herzlichen 4 j
ich denke ich werde es mir erstmal
natürlich nicht wollen weil der preis
wird zu teuer ist aber wenn ihr jetzt
natürlich so ganz viel geiler sein
sollen wir total von neuen funktionen
und alles mögliche dann werde ich mir
schon holen aber wenn das jetzt komplett
auf bewegungssteuerung setzt dann auf
gar keinen fall weil ich weiss nicht
wenn man so will man ja sitzen und wenn
man nicht sich rum haben will und blabla
da soll man sport machen und meine
meinung zur debatte
ach so du meinst das soll nicht so aus
wenn es da ja genau wenn das so was wie
kinect wird oder so was die playstation
move der mädchen auf gar keinen fall
wollen weil ich kein bock hab mich beim
takt zu bewegen er das glaube ich aber
auch nicht danach sollte es nicht aus
dass da mehr so nach hardcore gamer aus
und weniger nach wir müssen jetzt alle
familien ansprechen dass auch gamestop
bin ja gerade in der höhle hier und
warte auf das eine spinne komme ich
möchte irgendwann auch du gehst beenden
ja ich bin ich in der höhle
dachtest du dich auch aber dann habe ich
mich dann wieder umentschieden und jetzt
wo bist du denn abgeschlossen
er brennt brennt könnte theoretisch
zurücknehmen so habe ich dann meinen da
sage ich find auch mit fallenden
verschreiben ob das schwert jetzt gut
ist oder die folgenden tag erwischt aber
wieder auf jeden fall eine
abwechslungsreiche schwert
hast du das verzaubert 30
ich habe auf meinem schwer tat eines
einzelnen beck 13
du bist aus der expertin die schuld viel
bett tue ich werde es auch immer
verändern ich habe hier noch ein bogen
ja ich komme jetzt zurück wenn du willst
nenne ich geh zur hürde beim perfekt
ausgerüstet ich nicht als ich habe
einfach zu viel kraft dabei ich habe ein
ganz alles aus gewisser hass irgendwie
blake schon mal gefunden was heißt nur
die playstation 4 hat so dass dort aber
aber sag mir kurz of the players
ja habe ich doch ich habe diese festung
damaligen leute doch für die für die
allerdings kisten ja aber ich verstehe
ich warum ich immer alles investieren
muss investiert doch die ob sie den
gefahren
mit einer spitzhacke da war ich doch
keine hatte
das ist damit du deine diamanten
schützen kannst mein gott was da los war
ich nicht gekannten das update bist du
am ländern nehmen läuft ansonsten extrem
ein task manager aber da das heißt die
extorre bei dir ist jetzt auch
abgepackte wie hier die aufnahme ist
abgekauft ja aber ich kann mich wieder
neu starten heute die aufnahme soll muss
noch eine menge schnee ich mache gerne
habe ein auf einer höhe gefunden und das
vorbei das sieht doch schon gleich viel
besser aus
eisen so da bin ich wieder ich habe und
meine apps gehen runter total
perspektive auf seinem pc kaufen was
hast du für mich hatte
eigentlich würde ich dich immer fragen
weil wir der shader der 460 die panthers
wasser was hast du mal mit nvidia gtx460
overclock 24 dies voll alt und
altersstufen die auch diesen titel auch
keiner mehr haben die ägypter jetzt
wieder bei dir läuft scheider führt
deswegen fragen alle eigentlich läuft
flüssig gerade nicht aber gerade eben
weiß man warum ich in meinem neuen pc
ich weiß nicht ob ich eine nvidia
geforce gtx 680 mit 84 68 generation
komisch warum soll ich die sachen ein
ich habe ich ein grita bei 30 fps
patrick marleau wenn er noch eine mappe
nehme ich meinen traum an kraft
verlieren ich bin so als colt als ich
das sah man zu dingen
ich werde euch jemanden suchen jedoch
erst wieder nach hause weil ich will
auch diamanten suchen kinder klatschen
auch nicht weil sonst denke ich mir das
ist wahrscheinlich blüht gerade ist so
und so viele sachen inventar und
überhaupt nicht einen anderen habe ich
eigentlich schon mal ich bin radikal
ändern und dass die kacke ist sich
einfach nicht an ender perle wasser
brauchen wir brauchen eine haben wir
noch gar keine
doch ich hab schon ein habe ich mich
trotzdem noch eine und dann nachher
diese änderung machen dann stronghold
films entgehen fakt ist afrika aktiv was
schon wieder abgehakt wir hier unser
gewissen gemeinde senden und waren
einfach einen stopp danach lieber
folgenden war das jetzt mal folgen ende
nehmen dann mach ich mal einmal mit der
hier lässt er auch keine nation blogspot
mesic und heißt dich mal wieder hey
warum nur dort warten oder abgetan was
hat sie mir geschickt dass alle abgesagt
dem mann
obwohl gleich wieder gelöscht habe das
war ein kompletter cook minecraft ordner
haben komplett gelöscht und trotzdem
jetzt startet immer wieder ab nach der
folge deshalb nehme ich mal als neues
hier alles klingt so schön neu in diesem
jahr zwei typen und alba tür blieb aus
peter fox style peter fox klausel der
ist deutsch steht muss sich wieder mit
einem englisch ankommen peter fox
das mal hinhören wirklich auf dem platz
nichts vorschlagen würde sowas von tief
unten
die muss erst mal sortieren auch für 30
erst seine tolle spinne man bei mir ist
aber auch karten zurück liegt der fall
eventueller an dass der server zu wenig
am hut
nein das kann das kann an deinen klar
erklärt nicht gegen den willen höchstens
blogger sich nicht so schnell abbauen
lassen und so was alles ist so ist die
kacke als ein als mir egal
klicke einfach und jetzt nämlich gleich
nach der folge hier nämlich schon aber
auch zu playstation 4 hatte ich ja
eigentlich was zu sagen doch ich finde
das eigentlich finanz richtig gut dass
endlich endlich endlich eine neue
konsolen generation kommt weil auch die
ganzen pc spiele sozusagen begrenzt sind
weil die konsolenspiele nicht sehr gute
grafik und dann wird natürlich selbst
übt das pc-spiel was sein von der
konsole portiert wird kann auch nicht so
ne hammer mäßige grafiken darum gut
endlich wieder neue generation der
konsolen ist als schüler werden tolle
und schöner und gta wo jetzt verschoben
auf september
das könnte zusammenhängen des
playstation 4 rauskommt geht ja darum
erst plötzlichen viel erscheint deswegen
ganz neue möglichkeiten technisch sind
und die grafik doch nicht so kacke wird
und ruckelig wie bei gta 4
er geht ja fünf konzeptes und ich habe
mich auch auf der a 4 kombi stimmt
natürlich aber die sache ist natürlich
damit er die wie teuer wird das das
ganze vergnügen sein und die zweite
sache wie wird er die
abwärtskompatibilität sein also die
inwiefern kann man da seine playstation
3 spiele drauf spielen bei wendel 110
milliarden spiele für playstation 3 hat
und dies ist alles auf der playstation
in der spielbaren die ganzen freunde
haben auch noch ne ps3 man selbst ist
der einzige mit psp kann natürlich dass
es dann natürlich schon
schaden natürlich blöd 360 seit seit
sieben jahren die playstation auch er ca
ja ich glaub sechs jahre oder oder für
jeden fall ein bisschen kürzer als ex
post aber das ist so ein riesen langer
zeitraum
und irgendwann kommt muss etwas neues
kommen kann man nicht immer so selbe
wieder hornau
also ich denke auch ich werde es mir
eigentlich holen
also ich weiß es aber ich habe mir nie
eine playstation geholt also das klappt
es ja ich werde mir auf jeden fall für
gta dann wenn das auf einer neuen
konsole ist eine von beiden holen weiß
aber nicht welche bei mir gefällt die
xbox controller viel besser muss ich
halt wer sich nachher zeit an dem
playstation controller gewöhnen ich bin
mittlerweile im playstation controller
besser ja auf dich hat kann ich bin echt
nicht schlecht aus klasse 3 kind nicht
wann ich will diamanten finden auf
welche für bin ich jetzt eigentlich bin
ich auch für 11 ich hätte man bogen
verzaubern seien dazu gedacht dass ich
nächstes mal
ich fahre ich bin schon wieder level 4
mann ich fahre jetzt bis auf level 30
jahren verzauberten eiskalten bogen weiß
wie lange die folge noch geht er ist
jetzt gerade vorbei dann machen wir ein
cut zur nächsten folge und dann nehme
ich ein neuer minecraft freundin zwei
tagen wieder